you
you
you
all right hello everyone so we are going
to continue my science Q&A for science
and technology Q&A for kids and others I
think our theme for the last couple of
weeks has been things in science fiction
and to what extent they can be real and
I think we have a few saved up questions
which don't seem to be of that type
um okay well there's a question here
maybe I can start on this what is
imaginary about an imaginary number and
what does it represent us and what do
they represent and so on we owe I think
we're going to talk about that I have to
show you some things so let's see what I
can do there let me just um arrange this
so I can do that um and let me go ahead
and share this confusing I have multiple
screens here so there we go
okay all right let's talk about some
imaginary numbers okay so as a math
topic so let's talk about squares of
numbers to begin with so we say
something like two times two and a
computer we represent multiplication by
a star we know two times two is four
great we say like 6 times 6 36 these
numbers are squares
they're called squares because if we
were to have something with six boxes
along one side and six boxes going down
the total number of boxes that we would
make in a square will be 36 so so we can
work out
work out all kinds of squares so let's
make a table for example n squared and
going up to 10 so our friendly squares
of numbers so the big question is it's
all well and good to say that 2 times 2
is 4 something like that but what if we
had what if we asked about -1 what would
be what x what will be equal to minus 1
so the back come a long time ago
primarily a chap called Kedah know in
the 1500s I think maybe late 1400s -
early 1500s was trying to figure out the
answer that question what is if you
multiply what x what is equal to minus 1
and so he invented this thing he called
I and I was just supposed to be the
square root of minus 1 so if I say
what's the square root of minus 1 it'll
tell me it's I it writes it out as a
lowercase I but we type it in as a
capital I just because that's that's the
way that it's easiest to have the
computer understand what we're talking
about so the so the the if we have this
thing called I and we say what's I
squared the answer is minus 1 so we can
make a whole system of numbers that work
using using eyes so for example we can
say something like 2 plus I and we can
say what's 2 plus I squared and that'll
give us an answer and we can do all
sorts of things that we would normally
do with with with ordinary numbers in
terms of numbers that contain eyes
numbers that contain square roots minus
1 so here's a way to think about this um
gosh we can go in many different
directions here so we can think about a
number like 2 plus I let's say it's 3
plus I we can think about that as being
well okay so if we think about
coordinates we might be saying might say
let's say we say something like this we
have it we have a bunch of numbers let's
say we have the numbers 2 3 5 6 for
example we can plot those and let's
this gridlines automatic okay so there
we plotted those two points so that this
is plotted and let's just say a second I
make it clearer okay so we've got these
numbers these these points 2 3 5 6 so
this is coordinate x coordinate 2 y
coordinate 3 x coordinate 5 y coordinate
6 and that's how we can plot those two
points in on the plane well with complex
numbers we can say when we have a number
like 3 plus I so remember I represents
the square root minus 1 but it's just
this this thing that we can think of as
a just a thing we write down we don't
have to say what its value is it's just
a thing we write down that represents
the square root of minus 1 so similarly
we could say here we could say something
like come to call it complex list plot
because these are called complex numbers
we could say 2 plus 3i
oops 2 plus 3i 5 plus 6i and that we can
represent that the same way and so this
is this is called representing these
numbers in what's called the complex
plane where the horizontal coordinate
the x coordinate is the real part that's
just the 2 for example and the vertical
coordinate is the imaginary part that's
the thing that's multiplied by the I so
so we can we can think about these
complex numbers as being a way of
describing numbers that appear in in two
dimensions numbers that appear in the
plane and so on so that's that's some
and it's you might ask is there sort of
a generalization of something like
complex numbers that works like in three
dimensions or four dimensions or
whatever the answer is there it's a
little complicated the the idea of
having a number
represents has a real part in an
imaginary part is something fairly
specific to taking square roots and
there isn't really an analogue of that
in in in something like there's sort of
an analog in four dimensions things
called quaternions a sort of an analog
in eight dimensions things called octone
Ian's but these get to be wilder and
while the kinds of numbers but when it
comes to complex numbers um we can just
think of it there's just a rule that
says whenever you see I I squared is
minus one and if we say you know 2 plus
3i x 5 plus 6i we can just use standard
algebra to multiply this out it's 2
times 5 plus 3i x 6i so it's it's 2
times 5 is 10 and then 3i x 6i is 3
times 6 which I guess is 18 but the I
times I is minus 1 so then we'll get 10
minus 18 and so if we work this out we
should get minus 8 and then these are
the the cross terms which are just and
so if we were just to put X in there
instead of I we'd see this is what we
get so that and we say expand that out
we get this and that's showing us so the
only thing that's different here is x
squared we know is equal to minus 1 so
we can replace that x squared by minus 1
the X is just I here um so let me let me
explain okay one more thing about this
and then we'll get off the subject what
was Cardno originally trying to do when
he invented complex numbers so what he
was trying to do was he was trying to
answer question to solve an equation so
for example if we have the equation
let's say we have the equation x squared
equals 4 okay we can say what's the
solution to that equation so for what
value of x makes x squared equal to 4
and the answer will be either x is plus
2 or X is minus 2 either one of those
multiply them square them and we'll get
4 ok so now we can look at an equation
that says let's let's look at another
kind of equation let's
let's take a look at the equation let's
look at an equation x squared plus a
times X plus B equals 0 solve that for X
and let's let's look at this well let's
just look at this for x equals no
actually I'll tell you what I'm going to
do let's do this let's make a plot of
that function as a function of X from
let's say minus 10 to 10 oops minus 10
to 10 and let's make that let's
manipulate that plot with a going from
minus 4 to 4 B going from minus 4 to 4
okay so so for each so this is 4 let's
let's look at what these values are for
a equals minus 4 and B equals minus 4
that's what that function x squared plus
minus 4 minus minus 4 X minus 4 that's a
plot of that function so if we want to
know for what value of x is that equal
to 0 so like solving the equation x
squared plus plus minus 4x minus 4
equals 0 we can read off the answer here
it's just where this where this curve
crosses the axis okay so now let's
change the value up so we can say the
answer to that we can ask it to let's
let's have it actually show us the
answer here so let's say um let's do
this let's make that plot and then let's
also say and solve of x squared plus ax
plus B X plus plus B equals 0 solve that
for X ok so this is going to show us
let's let's make it let's put it on top
here let's say let's just say labeled
here so this is going to show us
hopefully it's going to show us the the
answer right so this is saying for a as
minus 4 and B is minus 4 that's telling
us the values of X where this where that
that thing x squared plus ax plus B is
equal to 0 is X is minus about 8.2
an X's plus 4.8 okay
so now let's change these values okay so
I'm now changing the value of a and we
can see this curve is moving a bit and
but it still was still getting nice
values down here we're still seeing how
that curve crosses this axis actually
let me I'm just gonna change one thing
here umm just it'll be a little easier
to see what's going on okay so as we
change a we'll see this curve keeps on
crossing the axis everything's all good
etc etc we're getting this is reading
off the values where the curve is
crossing the axis okay let's now start
changing the value of B okay the car is
moving up it's still crossing the access
all's good all's good all's good and now
eventually oops there's a problem what
is the solution for what values this is
trying to read off for what values of X
this curve crosses the axis but it
doesn't cross the axis there's no value
of x on this real line from minus 4 to
plus 4 for which this curve crosses the
axis instead it's crossing the axis at
this complex number value where X is
minus 0.3 minus 1.5 I and so what car
Nana was looking at actually he was
looking at cubic equations rather than
quadratic equations and he actually
ended up inventing both negative numbers
and imaginary numbers at kind of the
same time as things you absolutely
needed to understand the solutions to
cubic equations we can just for a little
bit more advanced kind of thing we can
take a look at what this thing looks
like in in the complex plane let's see
minus 5 minus 5i 5 plus I so this is
this is a slightly fancier thing this is
looking at um as is for people who know
how complex numbers work a little bit
more this is looking at um at where I
share you know what I'm going to make
this a 3d complex plot
this is showing is this is a 3d surface
that shows the magnitude of the complex
number and the color is the phase the
complex number when I'm when I'm
plotting the complex number as a as a
point in two dimensions the magnitude is
the distance from the origin to that
point and the phase is the angle between
the x-axis and the origin so as we move
what we'll find here as we move a and B
we'll move around the positions of those
places there those are the the roots of
that equation and they move around and
we can see them do all kinds of things
yeah that what-what happened there for
people who are into the math of what's
going on here that point
what happened as those as those things
move around that's the things on the
real axis as they move here there comes
to be that get to this critical point
and then the roots go off in the along
into the complex plane so okay there was
a little bit of an elaborate explanation
all right let's let's um let's let's go
back here and let me go back to to
answering sorry that was that that got a
bit mathy all right let's let some D
math here and let's come back and let me
just get to my to do this um we got a
bunch of questions here so I'm going to
try and start addressing those all right
stop sharing this okay
students okay well
to take these from the top here
how can one split atoms and why is it
difficult okay so let's talk about what
what's in an atom so we have an atom of
let's say oxygen nitrogen those are two
common gases in the air in the air
we have little molecules which are pairs
of oxygen atoms or pairs of nitrogen
atoms they're different kinds of
molecules water is two hydrogen atoms
one oxygen atom okay what are those
atoms those atoms have have two main
parts they have a bunch of electrons and
they have a nucleus that contains
protons and neutrons the nucleus is that
the whole atom is very small but the
nucleus is a hundred thousand times
smaller than the atom as a whole so the
nucleus is is this lump of protons and
neutrons that are in the center of the
atom and which kind of an atom it is
whether it's an atom of hydrogen whether
it's an atom of oxygen that's determined
by how many protons there are in that
nucleus and the the protons are so that
there are protons which have a charge
plus one and there are neutrons which
have no charge and so typical atoms have
roughly the same number of protons and
neutrons in them the usual form of atoms
has roughly the same number usually a
few more neutrons than protons
particularly when you get to heavier
elements in the periodic table okay so
what does it mean to split an atom well
a lot of times in chemistry the
electrons that are in the atom they're
pulled pretty far away from the nucleus
when you have for example chemical bonds
that's all the story of how the
electrons get pulled towards one nucleus
away from another nucleus all those
other kinds of things so the sort of
taking the electrons out of an atom it's
not a big deal that that's a there's a
sort of simple there's a electrical
force that holds the electrons into the
atom and lots of things in chemistry for
example pull the electrons a little bit
away from from the nuclear iron atoms
the real challenge is what about the
nucleus of the atom
how can you what what's involved in for
example can you take the nucleus of a
let's say uranium atom uranium has 92
protons the the typical isotope of
uranium well the most common isotope is
uranium 238 which has a total of 238
protons plus neutrons in its nucleus so
you've got this thing that's a bunch of
protons and neutrons stuck together and
the question is can you can you split
that nucleus apart can you turn that
that uranium nucleus and somehow break
it apart and turn it into nuclei of for
example other kinds of atoms so for
example back in the time of alchemy
before before modern chemistry back in
like their 1400s and things like this a
big obsession of people was could you
turn lead which is element number mmm
have to look it up it's around Oh see it
must be element eighty something 88
maybe um into gold which is element
number eighty it was there a way of
doing that and and that would involve
kind of messing around with the nuclei
of these atoms people didn't know that
back in the time when they were trying
to do alchemy but nobody figured out how
to do that so okay so what we this
question of splitting an atom it's all
about splitting this nucleus okay so the
first question is what holds the nucleus
together so one of the sort of physics
facts is when you have electrically
charged things they have they can have
positive charge they can have negative
charge unlike charges attract like
charges repel so when you have an
electron which has a negative charge
minus one charge and you have a proton
which has a plus one charge they will
electrically attract each other when you
have a bunch of protons they will
electrically repel each other because
they are two all charged plus one so you
might ask how does it succeed in being
the case but in the nucleus of an atom
like a uranium atom
you've got 92 protons sitting there in
very close proximity in you know 1,000
trillionth of a meter
across roughly you've got about nine
you've got 92 protons sitting there all
smushed together so question is how does
that work how do they manage to stick
together in nucleus that was figured out
in the 1930s um and the answer is as a
thing called the strong nuclear force
and the strong nuclear force is another
kind of force just like I mentioned the
electrical force between atoms is is
something that well attracts unlike the
electrical force between particles like
electrons and protons and things that's
that's one kind of force the strong
nuclear force is another kind of force
and the strong nuclear force has a
couple of characteristics that are
different from electromagnetism for
example in for electrical forces one
feature is that it's it's very
short-range electromagnetism there's an
inverse square law and you have things
far apart they will still be having an
electrical force of attraction but the
force of attraction will go down like
one over the square of the distance
between the objects the strong nuclear
force has as strong interaction between
things but it's only has a range of
about a thousand trillionth of a meter
there's very short range it's a range
comparable to the size of nuclei
actually but the strong nuclear force in
its simplest form has the feature that
unlike electromagnetism where like
things repel and unlike things attract
the strong nuclear force everything
attracts it's kind of like gravity in
that respect that there's everything is
is is is is kind of pulled together by
the strong nuclear force at least in its
simplest form okay so that's why so the
way nuclei held together is with this
strong nuclear force what actually is
the strong nuclear force so I have to
explain something about electrical
forces the way one thinks about
electrical forces in modern physics is
in terms of the exchange of photons or
so-called virtual photons so photon is a
cut is what occurs is kind of a particle
of light but there's a virtual version
of that a particle of light you can emit
some light and you can go you know
the other side of the universe and you
can if nothing was in the way that piece
of light that photon of light will go
all the way to the other side of the
universe but there's also a notion of
what's called a virtual photon which is
a photon that doesn't last very long
it'll be emitted by one thing and
absorbed by another thing and so
electrical forces work one way to think
about the way electrical forces work is
there's zillions of these virtual
photons that are being exchanged between
things and it's like one thing emits a
virtual photon and it's sort of pushed a
little bit away by that or pushed it's
it's moved by that by emitting that
virtual photon and then virtual photon
is sort of throwing to the to the other
thing and it absorbs it and it's pushed
a little bit by absorbing it or whatever
and it's this exchange of virtual
photons that causes the force of
attraction or repulsion to occur in
electrical forces okay so back in the
1930s a guy called Hideki Yukawa had
this idea that maybe the way the strong
nuclear force works is not through the
exchange of photons but through the
exchange of a new kind of particle that
he called a PI on of PI meson was the
original name and so a PI on is kind of
particle and it so photons are massless
particles and they have zero mass pi ons
have a mass that's about one-tenth the
mass of a proton and it turns out that
presence of mass is what makes the
strong nuclear force a short-range force
it's because the things that are being
exchanged at virtual particles between
protons there pi ons the virtual PI ons
and those virtual PI ons are because
their virtual pylons have a mass it
means they can't the virtual version of
them can't go very far more or less they
unlike the the electrical force law it
goes off like 1 over the square of the
distance the corresponding your Kawa
potential the the force associated with
virtual pile exchange
falls off exponentially with distance
and so that's so the protons can be
attracted to each other but only so long
as they're within about one thousandth
trillionth of a meter from each other if
they're further
part this force that comes from virtual
Payan exchanged sister disappears it's
infinitesimally small so when the
protons are really close they're stuck
together when the protons are pulled
apart they they they just fall apart
um okay so that's that's the basic way
that nuclear I held together is by
exchange of virtual PI ons by the strong
nuclear force I'll tell you a couple of
other funky things so there are a whole
zoo of particles that get exchanged that
cause the strong nuclear force there's
another kind cool Roma's ons or ro which
are which are somewhat heavier than PI
ons and basically what happens is you
take two protons when there are certain
distance apart they will be attracting
if you try and squash them together they
will start repelling each other and
that's in a first approximation due to
the exchange of Roma's ons
which have the property that they
produce a repulsive force and back a
long time ago I used to study particle
physics there was a thought that if you
push the protons even harder together
they might start attracting again
because of the exchange of what was that
those days called F bosons which were
even heavier particles which have you in
shorter range and you would have a
situation where if you could just squash
that nucleus
you know harder and harder harder
together suddenly you get boom the
nucleus would change its structure and
you get some new form of matter so
people thought that might occur it would
have been a big deal if it occurred
because it would have let will make all
kinds of energy from nuclei but turns
out that doesn't seem to happen it
doesn't seem to be possible to make kind
of compressed nuclei where they're where
they're making use of other features
beyond the ordinary strong nuclear force
to kind of bind the nucleus together
more strongly okay but ordinary nucleus
held together by the strong nuclear
force so if you want to break that
nucleus apart how do you do it well you
need to kick it really hard basically
turns out there are some nuclei that
spontaneously fall apart so in
particular uranium-235
the the version of uranium that has 92
protons and 235 minus 92 neutrons that
version because kind of the protons and
neutrons they're all sort of stuck to
but they probably because they don't
quite stick together if you have that
number of kind of sort of spherical
particles or something you don't quite
stick together in a nice way
probably that's a reasonable way to
think about it the the nucleus of
uranium-235 is unstable and it falls
apart and so it takes it a while to fall
apart actually it takes it on average a
billion years or more to fall apart and
that means that there were uranium-235 s
that were created there were atoms of
uranium-235 that were created when the
earth was created four and a half
billion years ago they're still around
they haven't yet to Cade they haven't
yet fallen apart but they're if you mine
a bunch of uranium some part of the
uranium will be uranium-235
and that uranium will be radioactive and
the form of radioactivity the form of
activity of the nucleus will be it falls
apart it's so-called spontaneous fission
spontaneous breaking a part of the
nucleus okay so you get a bunch of
uranium-235 uranium-235 spontaneously
falls apart so in a sense uranium-235
automatically splits the atom it splits
itself spontaneously but it does it
rather slowly it does it only it takes a
typical atom of uranium a billion years
or more to split apart so okay so now
the question is how do you use that to
to split other atoms so the answer is
when the uranium-235 splits apart it
produces it produces a bunch of stuff it
produces two kind of other smaller
nuclei and it produces a bunch of
neutrons the neutrons and the neutrons
kind of go off and if a neutron if one
of those neutrons hits another
uranium-235 nucleus it will kick the
uranium-235 nucleus hard enough that it
will spin it will immediately fall apart
it will undergo fission as well and when
that uranium-235 nucleus falls apart it
again will produce neutrons and
eventually you'll get a chain reaction
of more uranium-235 so en 235 falls
apart spawned
well the first one spontaneously falls
apart it produces neutrons
those neutrons hit other uranium-235
nuclei which would have spontaneously
fallen apart in a billion years but now
because they're being kicked by this
Neutron they fall apart easily and and
they then produced more neutrons and you
get this kind of chain reaction going on
okay so one of the reasons that doesn't
happen in nature is because you don't
have big lumps of uranium-235 sitting
around in in nature you have you'll have
uranium-235 mixed with uranium 238 - the
remaining 238 is the isotope of uranium
that has a total of 238 protons plus
neutrons and that is stable that doesn't
spontaneously fall apart so the big
challenge in making sort of splitting
atoms is to get enough for example
uranium-235 that you can have that chain
reaction occur and so that's a hard
process and it was done during the
Second World War that was the sort of
the big challenge in in making what was
done actually for it was the slightly
complicated story and it was done both
for nuclear reactors and for nuclear
weapons more or less the same time and
the essentially what you have to do is
you have to get a bunch of your own 235
you have to separate it from your own
238 that's a difficult process it's done
the most common way it's done these days
with centrifuges or you're basically
using its gas diffusion centrifuges
where but what happens is you have a gas
of uranium and it turns out the
uranium-235 uranium-238 it's
sufficiently much heavier than uranium
235 that if you spin the gas around very
fast the uranium 238 will tend to move
to the outside more quickly than
uranium-235 and that's how you manage to
separate the two things you take the
Iranian 235 you can use that to make
something which will undergo spontaneous
fission you then sort of have enough of
it together that it will have enough
neutrons that they will go and make more
efficient of other uranium-235 nuclei
and that's how you generate a nuclear
chain reaction and that's how you sort
of split law
of atoms and the once you have I mean
you can you can do it in other ways
basically what you need is a high-energy
particle and for example you can get
lots of high-energy neutrons by by this
cutting a part of your into 35 for
example but you can get high-energy
particles in other ways like with a
particle accelerator and so for example
the the original thing the alchemists
wanted to do of turning lead into gold
you could in principle bombard lead
nuclei with particles high-energy
particles and have them sort of fall
apart a bit and make gold it'd be very
inefficient way to do things and
wouldn't work very well but that's
something you can in principle do all
right bit of a long answer there um
let's see
as a question here is it possible to
make a
okay this is one question is it possible
to make an arc reactor as an Ironman I
don't know how that thing is supposed to
work so I don't really know I don't know
the I you know the question is can you
make a thing that generates just a lot
of power and be able to put it in a
small volume well we don't know how to
do that yet
there might be I mean it's just it's too
many ways one might speculate on how to
do that I mean I think the most ok the
thing that would be I've forgotten
what's what's the story in the movie but
but the thing ok in a normal the thing
that would be a really great source of
power is cold fusion what does that mean
so one way you can make I talked about
nuclear iron and how they work and one
of the things about nuclei is if you
were to take if you were to take two
nuclei of hydrogen which are just
protons and you were to somehow somehow
to get them to go together hard enough
that they would stick that the strong
nuclear force would take over so the
protons will tend to repel each other so
you have to put a lot of force into
getting neutrons to protons to get
together but if you can get the protons
if you can stuff them together with
enough force then the strong nuclear
force will take over and they will get
bound together and they will essentially
make a helium nucleus okay so where does
that happen well the most important
place for us where it happens is inside
the Sun the Sun is basically powered by
the fusion of hydrogen nuclei fusion of
protons which are the simplest hydrogen
nuclei and how does it work in the Sun
well in the Sun the temperature of the
center of the Sun is hydrogen Sun is
mostly made of hydrogen the hydrogen gas
is that temperature is basically a way
of saying that there's a lot of energy
in that hydrogen gas and these these
molecules of these atoms of hydrogen or
hydrogen nuclei are just being running
around an incredibly high speed and
so at that temperature when two hydrogen
hydrogen nuclei are going at the speed
that corresponds to that temperature and
they ram into each other they will
overcome the force of repulsion
associated with electrical forces and
they'll end up being pulled in by the
strong nuclear force and they'll make a
helium nucleus and when they get pulled
in to make a helium nucleus they
released a bunch of energy essentially
what's happening is they they the
healing nucleus is bound very tightly
together and the energy that's
associated with that binding is kind of
released in as the sort of strong
nuclear force takes over and and binds
things there's a binding energy that is
released as as energy as kinetic energy
of the helium nucleus so okay so in the
Sun one has hot nuclear fusion so to
speak one some one some ones using
temperature ones using the heat to just
give these give these nuclei enough
energy that when they ram into each
other they fuse okay
so similarly people have tried to
reproduce that so in a hydrogen bomb for
example the way it works says usually
the material that's used there it's not
hydrogen it's the most common I think is
lithium deuteride which is a just a you
know it's a they are using lithium
nuclei and and deuterium nuclei not some
not hydrogen nuclei but it's same same
idea um but um the the thing that the
thing that you're doing is in that case
is in a hydrogen bomb you actually use a
another user essentially another so
confusing thing about nuclei is you make
you generate energy by by fusing
together things like hydrogen nuclei you
can also make energy by breaking apart
things like uranium nuclei basically
what happens is for light nuclei fusing
them together makes energy for heavy
nuclei breaking them apart makes energy
the dividing line is iron-56
if you look in the periodic table at
iron iron
the place where anything lighter than
iron when you stuff the nuclei together
it makes energy and I think heavier than
iron when you break the nuclei apart it
makes energy so um the the way it works
is in hydrogen bomb for example there is
a a bomb that is basically made from
uranium plutonium one of that one of the
heavy elements that generates enough
heat to be able to push these these
atoms from a light element like lithium
or something together to make them fuse
and that releases even more energy
that's how it so called hydrogen bomb
works okay so the big question so
there's another people have been trying
okay when I was a kid people thought
that it was going to be possible to make
a nuclear fusion power station so to
speak well you would take hydrogen gas
and you were put it under enough you
would heat it up to the point where the
hydrogen nuclei would would be running
with enough energy but when they ran
into each other they would overcome the
force of electrical repulsion they would
be stuck together with the strong
nuclear force they would release energy
this was the idea and back in the 1950s
and 1960s people were like this is going
to work it's gonna work really soon
we're going to be able to make so-called
plasma fusion ok so plasma is something
like the solids liquids gases a plasma
is sort of the next phase of matter
where instead of having ordinary atoms
you have atoms where the electrons have
been stripped off so when you when you
heat an atom up to a high enough
temperature the electrons just get get
ripped away from the nucleus and you
just get sort of raw nucleus so the I so
what happens in a plasma what people try
to do is to get a plasma of hydrogen for
example which is just a basically
basically a bunch of protons running
around you heat it up let's say you heat
it up to ten million degrees centigrade
at that temperature there's a the the
hydrogen nuclei running around fast
enough but if two of them were to crash
into each other they would overcome the
electrical force of repulsion they were
oh they would they would and they would
get pulled together by the strong
nuclear force a nuclear fusion 210
million degrees centigrade it has a very
strong habit of like okay it's like you
heat up I don't know you have a balloon
or something in you you heats it up the
air will expand and the balloon will get
bigger the air is just trying to run
away very fast because it's been heated
up and it's just sort of running faster
away so by the time you get to ten
million degrees it's running away really
fast so the problem is to confine the
plasma to keep the plasma from running
away really fast so that you've got this
thing at ten million degrees centigrade
and you're able to to confine it to get
it stuck in this in this thing hard
enough that you get it enclosed so that
the atoms will so that nuclei will run
into each other and undergo nuclear
fusion okay so that's the idea so the
question is how do you make a box that
will contain hydrogen gas at a million
degrees centigrade and the answer is the
only known way to do that is to use
magnetic fields so you can you try and
make no material box know that you know
the highest temperatures at which things
melt are on the order of six thousand
degrees or something Oh forgets exactly
what is it it's some on the order of
tungsten is one of the higher
temperature things to melt and it's it's
maybe maybe some things maybe some
composite materials survive at higher
temperatures but by the time you're at
ten thousand degrees centigrade
everything's going to be are going to
have all the all the bonds that make you
a solid for example that could make you
make a box that all be broken apart so
by the time you're at ten million
degrees centigrade not a chance you're
not going to be able to make a solid box
of anything so the only thing the only
option is to make some other kind of box
and conveniently the protons are charged
particles they're all charged and so you
can use a magnetic field to to try and
confine those particles and so what
happened is people try to make all these
weird shapes of magnetic fields they
would have magnets in different places
they try and make a magnetic field
most common is wrinkled tokamak which is
a kind of toroidal magnetic field where
you where you have this this gas and
it's it's the the magnets arranged to
make a magnetic field that's in the
shape of a torus in the shape of a
doughnut with a hole in it and what
you're trying to do is to keep keep the
plasma at a million degrees think you
know confined inside this tokamak inside
this this toroidal magnetic field okay
so people thought this was going to be
reasonably easy turns out it was really
hard because what happens is the
hydrogen gas that the magnetic field
finds all these weird ways to become
unstable the hydrogen gas finds all
these weird ways to get out it's a bad
story so people have been trying to do
so-called magnetic confinement fusion
for about 60 years now a little bit more
than 60 years still hasn't worked
there's a big project being built in
South of France the thing's called the
thing called itter
which is a giant attempt to do plasma
confinement fusion and it will succeed
in confining a plasma to some extent and
there's been some level of confinements
been achieved it's by no means it's not
even close to being able to make like a
power station where you're actually
getting more energy out from from having
these from having nuclear fusion occur
than you put in maintaining the magnetic
field maintaining the temperature of the
plasma and so on okay so that's sort of
hot nuclear fusion and that's the thing
that everybody believes will work after
all we have you know in the sky every
day we have an example of hot nuclear
fusion working in the Sun okay so the
question is can you do cold fusion can
you do can you get hydrogen atoms to
fuse together in some way that isn't
based on heating that to very high
temperature to get them to just ram into
each other hard enough to overcome the
electrical force of repulsion so back in
the what was it 1980s I think maybe
early 1990s there was this experiment
reported that was called coke cold
fusion experiment so these guys
announced that they'd managed to get
hydrogen to undergo fusion in a
[Music]
in a way that didn't involve any high
temperatures and so there's a big big
sort of excitement and then people said
oh no the experiment was done wrong and
the experiment was faked and it was and
it wasn't real it wasn't you know cold
fusion is impossible
so people have believed ever since that
time that cold fusion is impossible most
people have believed that I personally
suspect that there may be a way to do it
and in fact if you look at the
experiment that was done it was an
experiment where palladium it's an
element similar to silver was used and
one very bizarre feature of palladium is
that hydrogen dissolves in palladium so
if you take a piece of palladium it's a
metal and you start putting hydrogen in
it it'll just absorb tons and tons of
hydrogen and so the hydrogen atoms will
just go and get themselves stuck inside
the palladium crystal and they'll find
out just for whatever reason palladium
just absorbs Orb tons of hydrogen and so
that kind of gives one an idea that
maybe maybe in the the Palladium is
somehow acting as some kind of matrix in
which you can put lots and lots of
hydrogen maybe you can put so much
hydrogen and so this palladium you know
crystal or whatever that eventually the
hydrogen's will be able to get close
enough that they'll undergo nuclear
fusion through the strong nuclear force
nobody managed to make that work yet but
it's not completely crazily impossible
but that could work and in fact I
wouldn't be surprised if one would not
find a way to to do cold fusion it
hasn't been proved possible so far but
it's one of these kinds of things where
people said oh the experiment is wrong
experiment doesn't work so it became
kind of a bad thing for physicists to
study and so nobody's studying it there
are by the way a bunch of companies that
are trying to do various forms of fusion
using essentially plasma fusion of
various kinds using fusion that based on
various other ways of firing particles
at each other and things like this you
you can get some amount of fusion to
happen just by accelerating one proton
to ram into another proton hard enough
you can accelerate it just using wheat
fields and things but you can't
a large number of protons to do that in
an easy way
but there's a bunch of companies just
nowadays that are trying to do various
forms of nuclear fusion as a way to make
power but if you ask me how wouldn't an
arc reactor and Iron Man style arc
reactor work I would say
cold fusion would be the best bet but we
don't know how to make cold fusion work
so so that one's not on the table yet
okay question here the question about as
a possible to make gravity sphere I'm
not sure what that is it's probably from
a piece of science fiction I don't know
so somebody can explain that I'll try
and talk about it there's a question
about the fifth force what is it and how
does it work okay let me I can I can
talk about that um so in um but by the
way I should I should say something we
talked about how the strong nuclear
force okay so what are the so called
forces of nature usually there are four
of them identified two of them are
pretty familiar and two of them are
somewhat unfamiliar so the two that are
familiar are electromagnetism and
gravity so electromagnetism force of
attraction or repulsion between
electrically charged things gravity
force of attraction between things with
mass those are two long-range forces
there for slower goes down like with the
inverse-square one over R squared
gravity we can think of as due to the
exchange of virtual gravitons
electromagnetism we can think of as the
exchange of virtual photons okay there
are two other forces that are talked
about one is the strong nuclear force
but I've been talking about a bunch
today that is more or less due to
virtual pile exchange at least in its
simplest form in nuclei there's sort of
a more modern version of that when we
think about protons and neutrons and so
on protons and neutrons are particles
that can exist separately on their own
but inside protons and neutrons are
quarks and gluons gluons are particles
exchanged between quarks that bind
together quarks and quarks have the
property that unlike other things there
are no you can't separate quarks to
infinite eight so I mentioned the the
law for electromagnetism the force law
goes down like one over R squared as you
as you make as you pull two charged
particles further apart the force of
attraction between them or force of
repulsion between them decreases like
the one over the square of the distance
between them okay you do the same kind
of thing with quarks they are pulled to
by gluons being virtual gluons being
exchanged between them but with virtual
glue on exchange instead of that going
down like an inverse square law it
actually increases it actually roughly
increases linearly with distance so as
you try and pull - quacks apart the
force with which they pull themselves
together increases as you pull them
apart it's a really weird thing and
roughly the reason that happens is
whereas with electromagnetism if you
have a charged particle and it's it's
producing it's it's going to attract
some other charged particle I mentioned
that's due to the exchange of virtual
photons roughly what's happening is one
charged particle you can think of
roughly as emitting virtual photons in
all directions but the virtual photons
don't interact with each other so all
these virtual photons just stream out
from the charged particle if they meet
another charged particle they get
absorbed by that and they cause a force
of attraction or repulsion between these
particles um and so what's happening is
if you imagine that a certain number of
these of these virtual photons are
streaming out from a charged particle in
all directions so if you know the math
of this thing if you have a certain
number of let's say you have you know
some number of these of these particles
they're going out in all directions the
the the density of these particles will
go down like the the one over the square
of the distance you can think about that
let's say you've got a thousand virtual
photons all being emitted from this
electron or something at the center
those thousand virtual photons if you
say what is the density of those virtual
photons on a sphere of radius R well the
the the surface area of that sphere is 4
PI R squared and so that means that the
the number the density of you've got a
thousand virtual photons coming out the
the the the density of those will be a
thousand divided by four PI R squared
and so that that explains kind of why
the why the force law for
electromagnetism goes down like the
inverse square it's because the number
of virtual photons going in a particular
direction will be
we'll be reduced by the inverse square
of the distance that your of the think
that the thing is apart okay so that's
how it works with electromagnetism with
so called color charge with exchange of
gluons between quarks the big difference
between gluons and photons is that
gluons are or some massless particles
but gluons interact with each other so
photons they don't intrinsically
interact with each other you have two
beams of light the beams of lights they
have things like interference phenomena
that's for a different reason but the
actual photons of light don't interact
the two beams of light can just pass
right through each other the photons
don't interact okay and in full
disclosure when you do full quantum
electrodynamics there is a tiny there's
an effect called light by light
scattering which is a tiny effect where
photons can interact with each other but
it's a very very short range of fact but
the photons have to hit just dead-on and
people are interested in the physics of
it it's a um it's due to the it's a it's
a so-called box Fineman diagram where
you have two but two photons coming in
and they produce an electron-positron
pair and that electron-positron pair is
then Rhian aya lights and produces two
other photons and that's what leads to
light by light scattering but like my
light scattering is is not um the the
sort of it so I think one over R to the
eights force associated with light by
light scattering but it's really tiny
and it has a tiny coefficient so it's
irrelevant light by that scattering is
not really a thing so photons there's no
intrinsic interaction between photons
the the there's no intrinsic law that
says that photons can can interact with
each other okay gluons completely
different story gluons intrinsically
interact with each other it's a
consequence in physics it's a it's some
well fancy math the it's because some
the the group of symmetries the internal
group of symmetries it's an abelian
group in the case of electromagnetism
it's a non abelian group in the case of
the SU 3 local gauge invariance of of
Grande Amex which is the theory QCD
which is the theory of quarks and gluons
let me not go down that that rabbit hole
I can I could that would take me a
probably 15 minutes to explain what I'm
talking about there but the basic bottom
line is gluons interact with each other
photons don't interact with each other
but gluons do interact with each other
okay so imagine you have a quark quark
emits a bunch of gluons okay so if it
was emitting photons the photons would
just stream outwards and the number of
photons on a sphere of radius R would go
down like one over R squared etc but the
gluons interact with each other so
instead we're just streaming outwards
all independently let's say you emitted
a thousand blue ones those gluons are
all trying to interact with each other
as gluons are all attracting each other
and so what happens is that instead of
streaming outwards in all directions the
gluons are all clumped together and they
essentially make this sort of string
that goes between the quarks so the
gluons you've got this quark and the
gluons are so stringing outwards they
all come together in this string and so
what's happening is between these two
quarks you've got this kind of string of
interacting gluons and they they that
that string of interacting gluons
instead of the number of gluons that
going down like an inverse-square law
the number of gluons well in that
approximation stays constant because
they're all clumped together in this
kind of string that goes between these
two quarks and that's why the lore of
that's that sort of a qualitative
explanation of what's called court
confinement the reason that the force
law between quarks increases as you go
to greater distances and as a result
these quarks can't be separated and you
can't you don't have any free quarks
they only exist inside protons and
neutrons and so on now what really
happens is you pull these quarks
apart far enough there's so much energy
associated with this gluon the sort of
chain of gluons between them there's so
much energy associated with that you
actually stop producing other particles
purely from energy from kind equals
mc-squared type type rules you're
actually producing additional particles
from that and so that's that's what
happens that's in in in particle physics
when you have high-energy particle
interactions and you get kind of quarks
streaming out from you know being
being kicked out very fast from a big
from an interaction between two
high-energy protons you might get jets
of that are led by a quark that's going
out with their high-energy as the as the
court tries to pull away it's
essentially pulling this string of
gluons very hard and it pulls it so hard
that the string gluons will break in
many places forming additional little
strings where there's a quark and an
antiquark typically together that that
can happily go off and be sort of that
those make like like a nap ion so in a
proton the main thing that's in a proton
is three quarks and a bunch of gluons in
a Payan there's a quark and an anti
particle of a quark and that's it's a
different kind of particle called Amazon
and the that term that's how what's
inside pylons okay so the strong nuclear
force the sort of classical view of it
is it's due to Pi on exchange the
slightly more modern view of it is it's
due to all these things with quarks and
gluons and it's associated with gluon
and interactions of gluons okay so
that's all we know about three forces
we've got gravity the weakest force
electromagnetism the next weakest force
then we've got the strong nuclear force
or QCD theory of quarks and gluons okay
there is a there is a fourth kind of
force which is traditionally called the
weak nuclear force the weak nuclear
force for a long time it only did one
thing it only led to nuclear beta decay
so some kinds of of nuclei fall apart as
a result of emitting electrons so that
happens actually if you have autre tiem
for example the the the nucleus that is
the an isotope of hydrogen that contains
one proton and two neutrons tritium is
unstable with a decays in about 1020
years something like that and what it
does to decay is proton proton Neutron
it emits an electron together with the
nutrient anti neutrino and it
turns into what does it turn into it'll
turn into some helium isotope I think um
but in case it decays by emitting this
electron and so for a long time the weak
nuclear force the only thing it did was
to lead to nuclear beta decay okay so it
actually when I was a kid it was my
favorite so the particle physics thing
was the weak nuclear force it has a lot
of interesting properties actually
another thing it does is it leads to the
decay of pi massan's soap ions it's a
modern name for a PI meson pi ons decay
there are three kinds of pi ons
positively charged negatively charged
and neutral pylons the positive and
negative charged ions decay in about ten
to the minus eight seconds one hundred
millionth of a second and they decay
into usually a muon and a neutrino and
the neutral pi on pi zero decays into
two photons and it decays in about ten
to the minus sixteen seconds that's a
10,000 trillionth of a second it neutral
pylons fall apart into two photons so
the the plus and minus pi ons PI plus
and pi minus which decay into muons and
neutrinos or sometimes electrons and
neutrinos that decay process is another
example of the action of the weak
nuclear force okay so what leads to the
weak nuclear force being as weak as it
is well the answer is the weak nuclear
forces also just like all these other
forces you know gravity is the exchange
of gravitons electromagnetism is the
exchange of photons the strong nuclear
force in one interpretation is an
exchange of ions and other
interpretations that exchange of gluons
depending whether you're looking at at
level of protons are we looking at level
of their the quarks that are inside them
the the weak nuclear force is due to the
exchange of things called W bosons so W
bosons were sort of predicted
theoretically and then were found in the
1980s
[Music]
in hzr 1980s the they and so the writer
was it seven days no it must I think it
was the late 70s or early 1980s um the
um so w bosons are another kind of thing
that can be exchanged between quarks
between electrons between a bunch of
different kinds of particles and they
they lead to another kind of force but W
bosons are even soap ions are about
one-tenth the mass of an electrode on W
bosons are eighty times the mass of a
proton and and so that additional mass
makes the weak nuclear force in a sense
even shorter range than the strong
nuclear force and weaker in some sense
than the strong nuclear force and so
that's that's another kind of force is
the force associated with the exchange
of W bosons there's actually things
called Z bosons which are another type
of weak nuclear force but so those are
the the four forces gravity
electromagnetism the strong nuclear
force or QCD and the new weak nuclear
force associated with W bosons okay so
apart from gravity those other three
kinds of forces all kind of work sort of
the same way they are all exchange of a
certain kind of particle it's called the
gauge boson and they all they the
mathematics of how they work is is quite
much the same and that the so-called
standard model particle physics is a
model that combines QCD with the weak
nuclear force and electromagnetism okay
so the question is are there any other
forces that we messed here are there any
other kinds of particles we could
exchange which would lead to forces
between things and so people have had
various different theories about what
other kinds of particles might exist
none have been found there are
occasionally experiments that say that
people have observed things that might
occur on different distance scales and
things like that
but nothing's ever been found so right
now we have those are the those are the
forces that are known there is an idea
called supersymmetry
which leads to some other kinds of
forces but none of them have ever been
observed so it's it's something that
sort of out there is a thing to study
but it hasn't been hasn't actually been
found
so okay so that was an answer to that
I've got all kinds of my gosh so many so
many questions here um as a question
down here I see from a Thomas H 10 are
there more substances or elements that
work like palladium for cold fusion I do
not know the answer to that I think
people have claimed that there might be
um I don't know as a question here from
Brian where does the energy come from to
emit all those virtual gluons oh boy
you're you're having me
dive into quantum mechanics and quantum
field theory here here's how things
roughly work normally there's a law of
energy conservation and well let's see
how to explain this
let me explain it a different way
normally something like a photon or a
gluon is massless you just have a photon
it it travels at the speed of light
because it's massless it travels at the
speed of light if you if you if you you
can't slow it down but if you could and
you could weigh it it would have zero
mass now when okay this is a little
complicated so in quantum mechanics the
there's this thing called the
uncertainty principle which essentially
says that so one of the things it says
is if you try and measure the energy of
something it takes you a certain amount
of time to measure that energy
accurately if you're only allowed a very
short amount of time to make the
measurement you'll never be able to
accurately measure the energy of
something so if the time is short enough
the energy measurement will be uncertain
by a certain amount and in fact there's
a the the usual and certainly relation
says the the amount of difference the
amount of error and energy measurement
multiplied there by the amount of time
you're measuring it is always greater
than this constant called H h-bar the
Planck's constant a very small number
it's about well energy time it's about
10 to the minus 34 joule-seconds so in
in other words in if you wants it to be
uncertain by a whole Joule of energy
that you could if you if you only made a
measurement for 10 to the minus 34
seconds you would have an uncertainty of
10 to the of one Joule of energy okay so
the way it works is if you measure only
for a very short time you have an
uncertainty about your energy and so
what that and you also have an
uncertainty because energy and mass go
together through equals mc-squared you
also have a set and certainty about mass
so what that means is if you have a
photon and you only take you're only
measuring it for a trillion trillionth
of a second you can't know what its mass
is and so what happens is a virtual
photon is basically a photon whose mass
isn't zero but it only connects
list for let's say a trillionth of a
second and so the way that that the sort
of the energy budget works is energy is
conserved when virtual photons are
emitted energy is conserved but the mass
of the photon isn't the mass you think
it is it's a different mass in the
language of particle physics oh it's a
never mind it's it's in the the it's
kind of a silly word it's always it said
the photon is off its mass shell and
it's called that because there's a
vector that represents the momentum the
for momentum the energy momentum of the
photon and you say P squared the energy
of momentum squared which kind of
represents the surface of a sphere and
it always reminds me of crabs on the
half shell and other things that I can't
stand eating those things but that's
different this year
um the but anyway the the idea is
virtual photons don't have to have the
ordinary mass of a photon and that's how
kind of the energy budget of emitting
virtual photons virtual gluons and so on
works
um the
um oh boy somebody is some is asking
here what is energy I might be the wrong
person to ask it of right now because we
finally have a theory of physics where
we can actually answer that question but
it's a slightly long story all right let
me just look at a couple of other okay
there's a question here about fusion
again the from Lex here is helium-3 and
minerals useful for fusion I don't know
there was a there was a crazy effort to
try and mine helium-3 from the moon
having something to do with fusion I
don't know whether it's really very
useful helium-3 is a wonderful and
bizarre thing um I don't know of other
other minerals on the moon but they
useful I mean the fact is helium very
light elements our atmosphere has very
little heat has essentially no helium in
it the reason is that um okay so at a
certain the the force of gravity on the
earth is sufficient that when you have a
big enough atom like oxygen for example
the force of gravity on the earth will
make oxygen will will keep oxygen kept
inside our atmosphere a hydrogen because
it's a lighter element it manages to
escape the Earth's gravity on Jupiter
for example which has much higher
gravity than the earth hydrogen does not
escape and so the atmosphere of Jupiter
is mostly made of hydrogen on the earth
the atmosphere of the earth the hydrogen
and helium which are very light elements
they escape the Earth's atmosphere and
so we lost the the earth might have had
hydrogen helium when it was first
created four-and-a-half billion years
ago but they escaped a really long time
ago and so we're just stuck with
nitrogen and oxygen in our atmosphere
and and sly and the trace amount of
heavier things like xenon and so on in
our atmosphere
um and
the butt so on the earth there actually
is quite a lot of helium in the earth
but it's trapped under rocks inside the
earth trapped presumably from when the
earth was formed there is a certain
amount of helium helium is very
non-interactive doesn't form compounds
with other other elements to speak of um
and but you can get a fair amount of
helium from the earth and people people
people sometimes worry the helium is
gonna run out in the earth I don't think
that's right
and so people talked about mining helium
from the moon which seems funky helium
comes in in two primary two primary
stable isotopes helium has two protons
in its nucleus helium four which is the
most common type of helium has two
protons and two neutrons helium three
has a proton a two protons on one
Neutron helium three has some wonderful
properties it's a very bizarre kind of
thing
it is a item okay so I'll tell you a
little story about helium-3 III at one
time had a big kind of this was in the
early 1980s okay a little bit of a story
here so the weak nuclear force which I
was talking about earlier the weak
nuclear force has effects electrons and
effects protons it effects all kinds of
things but there's one kind of particle
which none of the other forces affect
but only the weak nuclear force effects
and that's particles called neutrinos
neutrinos have almost zero mass they
seem like they don't have exactly zero
mass but neutrinos are emitted in
nuclear beta decay they are their
particles that have that are very they
have very little interaction because the
only interaction they have is through
the weak nuclear force and so hylia
neutrinos for example that the amount of
interaction they have increases as their
energy increases but the kinds of
low-energy neutrinos of the kind that
are produced in nuclear reactors for
example they they just go through the
earth
typical neutrino will just go straight
through the earth and in fact there been
a bunch of neat experiments that have
been done where neutrinos are like
produced in a particle accelerator in
Illinois and they're sent through the
earth and they're picked up again by
detectors in Canada um so neutrinos
basically just go through the earth most
of the time they're they interact with a
very very low probability and their only
form of interaction is through the weak
nuclear force so and and so for example
that yeah and by the way the Sun
produces neutrinos was the biggest two
years ago because it didn't seem like
the Sun was producing enough neutrinos
and people were kind of freaking out
maybe the maybe the center of the Sun
has gone out because the center of the
Sun it takes a photon at the center of
the Sun ten million years to get to the
surface of the Sun Sun is very opaque it
looks some just a very it takes takes a
long time for the light to get from the
center of the Sun to the outside and so
but neutrinos because they don't
interact very much neutrinos from the
center of the Sun from the place where
the Sun is hottest in the middle
neutrinos just go straight out to the
outside and so there were experiments
done to try and detect neutrinos coming
from the Sun and the earliest
experiments that were done just didn't
see neutrinos the experiments were done
by having deep minds where there aren't
other particles because there's a big
couple of miles of rock that absorb all
the other particles and the only things
that go through those couple of miles of
rock are neutrinos and so then big tanks
of used-to-be liquids but also some
solid ones that were made but big
detectors that we're basically you're
looking for that one solitary neutrino
out of trillions and trillions in Russia
knows that one solitary neutrino that
happened to hit the nucleus just right
on and I threw the weak nuclear force
interacted with that nucleus and
produced some and managed to produce an
electron for example and then you detect
the presence of that electron in your
detector and that's some and so people
built these these big detectors for
neutrinos and the big problem was in the
earliest such detectors they didn't see
anything now it's always very suspicious
when you look at at experiments
difficult physics experiments and the
experiment says I saw nothing because
it's hard to know was that because there
was nothing to see or was that because
you glitched somehow
your experiment wasn't quite set up
correctly and so it just wasn't set up
to see something um so it turned out in
the case of the neutrino solar neutrino
experiments there was a mistake in the
experiments and insurance were there the
Sun hasn't gone out all as all as well
later experiments were sensitive to
neutrinos which came from slightly more
central kinds of reactions in the Sun
the earliest experiments were sensitive
to a um a very an obscure kind of
reaction that happens rather
infrequently in the Sun and had to be
calculated what frequency was and it was
a little bit difficult to calculate but
anyway so it's a story of neutrinos ok
so nuclear reactors produced neutrinos
um and they produced them and the
neutrinos from nuclear reactors just as
I mentioned just go through the earth
okay so one place where there are
nuclear reactors is nuclear submarines
so nuclear submarines they stay under
the ocean for long periods of time and
they're powered by nuclear reactors and
they use nuclear reactors because it's a
way you don't have to carry it or a fuel
you just have to carry some nuclear fuel
which is just much more efficient than
any other form of fuel so that means
they don't have to go and refuel all the
time ok so nuclear reactors so one of
the one of the sort of schemes in the
world is you know particularly us and so
what was the Soviet Union in those days
had lots of nuclear submarines and the
idea was there are nuclear submarines
prowling around under the oceans and
nobody knew where any of them were and
that was sort of an important piece of
the story of you know don't shoot a
nuclear missile at us because you won't
be able to take out our nuclear
submarines and they'll come and shoot
missiles back at you but that idea
depends on the idea that the nuclear
submarines you can't find where the
nuclear submarines are so yep so one of
the issues is the nuclear submarines
emit neutrinos and nuclear submarines so
you got a nuclear submarine and it's
producing neutrinos but neutrinos are
really hard to detect so most of the
time your your nuclear submarines are
completely safe you can't tell where
they are at least not by looking at
neutrinos coming from their reactors um
okay so that's a long shaggy story but
some
in the 1980s I was thinking about is
there a way to make what's called a
coherent detector of neutrinos so with
when you have an antenna which detects
an electromagnetic wave the way that
works you can have a pretty big antenna
and the the it's detecting an
electromagnetic wave and sort of the
whole antenna is is cooperating and
detecting the electromagnetic wave that
radio wave for example for neutrinos it
seemed like you would never be able to
get that kind of coherent neutrino
antenna you would always have to say
open the neutrino hit that item and sure
you hit that atom and the chance of that
happening is absolutely infinitesimally
small but if you could make a neutrino
antenna you'd have a completely
different story and you would be able to
detect neutrinos quite efficiently and
so I I've tried to calculate it turned
out the properties of superfluid helium
3 might have led to the possibility of a
neutrino antenna basically and that I
had this difficult problem because I I
tried to work this out and I kind of got
a fair distance in working it out and it
looked like it was going to work and it
was like oh my gosh what do you do
because you have this thing that you can
imagine building flying in a satellite
that is a coherent detector of neutrinos
which would be a neutrino antenna which
will basically detect the positions of
all the nuclear submarines and so I had
this I was actually pretty happy that
this didn't work but I had this kind of
difficult dilemma what do you do if you
know how to do this and and the way it
would have been done was using
properties of the liquid phase of a very
cold version of helium-3 cooled down to
a temperature where it becomes a liquid
where it becomes a superfluid and it has
certain weird properties that
potentially could allow you to make you
night antennae but perhaps fortunately
that's one of these sort of ideas that
didn't work out um and
that Tim so that that was that was the
let's see um alright I probably should
wrap up in a few moments here gosh let's
see um questions about quantum computing
and so I'm happy to try and answers and
other time those will be longer
questions to answer somebody wants to
talk about aliens and UFOs and
transgenics I'm happy to talk about that
but that's a longer story
[Music]
let's see gosh um boy there are a lot of
interesting questions here I have to
read off some of these questions because
I'm really going to enjoy trying to
answer these um Wow ok there's a
question here
if a haha okay all right this one I can
do if a matter black hole collided with
an antimatter black hole the same mass
what would happen okay that's a really
simple answer
there aren't antimatter black holes
there are matter like electrons and so
on there are always antiparticle
versions of electrons there in the case
of electrons or positrons things with
opposite electric charge um well
actually I'm about to say something
slightly wrong okay all right black
holes which come from collapsed stars
that have collapsed under their own
gravity where they've they're sort of
that this gravity is so strong that even
light can't escape from them eh okay
this is kind of interesting all right
black holes don't come in matter and
antimatter versions black holes are just
there's a black hole and there's no anti
black hole and the reason for that is
because mass is always positive there's
no version of mass that's negative you
there's no negative mass objects that
exist every particle has a positive mass
even an anti-electron has a negative
electric charge but it has a positive
mass and so far as we know and actually
this theory of physics of ours kind of
explains this mass is always a positive
number it's never okay for ordinary
particles and things always a positive
number the I mentioned virtual particles
you can have negative mass virtual
particles but they don't lost they can
only be temporary there's also a
possibility of negative mass in the
universe from dark energy that's a whole
different story but for ordinary
particles ordinary stuff one deals with
everything has positive mass even though
it can have opposite signs of charge so
for black holes there is no anti black
hole it's always just because mass is
always positive it's always a positive
mass black hole okay two footnotes one
is there are things called white holes
which are believed not to exist in our
universe a black hole everything falls
into a black hole and it's stuck in the
black hole why
tole everything streams out of the white
hole and it's like a time reverse black
hole like everything if you ran the
movie strip in Reverse in a black hole
everything's falling into the black hole
in a white hole you ran the movie strip
in Reverse everything comes out of the
white hole so far as we know white holes
can't exist in our universe and it's
kind of the same reason as as eggs don't
spontaneously unscramble themselves
things tend to get more disordered that
that turns out to imply that you can
have things sort of attracting under
gravity which you can't have this sort
of can't have this explosion of stuff
coming out of a white hole okay the
thing where I was stopping myself
earlier was the following issue so there
are electrically charged black holes in
the fancy language of relativity their
so-called rise in a Nordstrom black
holes
um the so um
black holes have a mass it's all they
have you can also have black holes that
have a mass and an electric charge and
so the thing I was wondering is you can
have black holes with the both a
positive electric charge and a negative
electric charge so the question is what
happens if you have two black holes that
have opposite signs of charge there's
anything interesting happened so when
you have two black holes they merge
together the the gravitational wave
detector a couple of years ago saw the
incredible amount of energy that's
released when two black holes merge
together in fact the black holes they
saw they released in about a second as
much energy as would be released by
having the Sun turn all the matter in
the Sun into pure energy and there was
so much energy that was released and
detected as a gravitational wave that
that gravitational wave even though that
that that merger of black holes occurred
a third of the way across the universe
it was possible to detect that on earth
because so much energy was released all
in a second so the the question that was
I was wondering about is if you have
electric charges and these black holes
and you have particular if you have
large electric charges does that affect
their like the the the the merger
mechanism for black holes the answer is
I think not to a significant extent
unless the electric charge is huge if
they're ultracar charge is huge you have
a bizarre effect called the naked
singularity in the black hole and it is
believed that it's not possible for
naked singularities to occur from the
collapse of stars
again many footnotes to that issue so I
think that you can't get a large enough
charge in a black hole in our universe
it'll the charge will all get sort of as
that as the star collapses to form the
black hole it will it will just split
out those pieces of charge they won't be
part of the the thing that collapses to
the black hole I think um
let's see
let's see those are questions about
imaginary numbers sorry I'll talk about
that another time that people are
interested
about the size of animals on earth that
makes us conscious could the weather
systems on large planets or galaxies be
conscious I think that's a deeply
slippery slope that has to do with the
definition of consciousness I think the
answer is to that is yes you know the
weather can have a mind of its own the
problem is that its mind is not a mind
that we understand the only minds that
we understand are human-like Minds and
so we say those are human-like minds
even animals other than humans on the
earth we don't understand their minds
enough to know whether we would count as
conscious in the human way they're
conscious but that's a longer discussion
it's a question here I let me just
address this a little bit the force of
friction how is it explained in terms of
the four fundamental forces friction is
sort of happening at a different level
so friction is when you rub two surfaces
against each other
they tend to resist being being slid
against each other friction is a force
happening at a much longer distance
scale in these other forces friction is
a confusing force one of the most
confusing things about friction is that
in ordinary friction if you push things
down if you if you if you have a heavier
thing the frictional force increases
roughly linearly with D that with the
heaviness of the thing or if you push
something down the if you push it down
twice as hard the force of friction the
resistance to sliding will be twice as
great and that linearity of friction is
not well understood even today it was
discovered at anta nuns what is it
called has a has not very it's usually
just called the lower friction that it
has was discovered in the 1600s I think
as a as a sort of mathematical law it's
still not very well understood but
what's happening in friction is roughly
when you look microscopically at two
surfaces they are like two giant that
like mountainscapes
except the mountains are at the scale of
atoms and when you're sliding these
these these surfaces against each other
those mountains as kind of sliding on
each other
and if you got those mountains if this
if the if the if the surfaces were
perfectly precisely flat and you weren't
in the air you're in a vacuum in space
for example and you have these two
surfaces and they're perfectly flat and
you put these two surfaces next to each
other
well it turns out they just they just
stick the atoms in one surface just will
stick to the atoms and the other surface
at least if they're the same kinds of
atoms for example in other words you
have two crystals of let's say silicon
or something and they're perfect
crystals they have perfectly flat faces
and they're in a vacuum there's no
little layer of air in between them
putting together they'll stick together
there isn't there isn't friction things
just stick together they'll form
basically form one crystal on in in
actual materials they'll tend to have
these rough surfaces and for reasons
that are still not particularly well
understood the the forces between the
atoms and these rough surfaces are such
that they're roughly the friction force
is roughly proportional to the normal
force to the force which you push the
thing down and the but those forces are
due to these little sort of
mountainscapes
kind of rubbing against each other and
when the mountainscapes get really close
they will try and just linked together
like like perfect crystals will link
together in a vacuum but that force
isn't really well understood and it's
it's a it's a sort of operating at a
different scale it's operating the scale
of many many atoms rather than at the
scale of individual particles um
oh boy there's a
from Brian about some hard light as in
keeping protons for keeping photons
still like an a like in a a lightsaber
or something like this well we don't
know how to do that with photons I don't
think it's gonna work with photons if as
I mentioned gluons interact with each
other but gluons interact so strongly
with each other that you can't just like
you can't pull quarks apart
you can't pull gluons apart either so
you can't get your full kind of full
effect lightsaber or something made out
of gluons so we don't know how to do
anything like that
at this time um
you
okay there's all kinds of there's a lot
of interesting questions here I probably
should um um oh let's see the question
here is is it known whether antimatter
falls under gravity or doesn't yes that
experiment was finally done only about
twenty years ago
somebody got antiprotons and they
checked antiprotons fall under gravity
one wasn't absolutely sure of that until
that time people thought antiprotons
would fall under gravity and have
positive mass but they weren't
absolutely there's two different things
having positive mass by virtue of the
inertia of the proton that was known but
having positive mass as in you can that
the thing falls under gravity just like
an ordinary particle falls under gravity
that wasn't known for sure until about
twenty years ago it was thought when I
was a kid for example it was there was a
serious possibility that half the
galaxies in the universe
might be anti galaxies half the galaxies
in the universe might be made of
antiprotons and antineutrons of
positrons rather than protons and
electrons and it's actually very weird
thing that there's more matter than
antimatter in the universe actually I I
worked on that back and forty years ago
or something trying to explain why that
was I think we now do have at least a
somewhat reasonable theory for why
there's more matter than antimatter in
the universe and it's for very subtle
reasons having to do with things that
happened in the universe at less than a
trillionth of a second after the
beginning of the universe basically
there were processes that led to there
were decay maybe we don't know this for
sure because it it involves some physics
theories which we don't actually know a
correct but probably it was some was due
to things that happened some fraction of
a trillionth of a second after the
beginning of the universe that had a a
difference between between particles and
antiparticles that led to a
preponderance of matter of antimatter
you know one of the mysteries one of the
other mysteries I'll just mention is
when you look at molecules like sugar
for example dextrose dextrose you know
if you know Latin dexter means right in
latin right that's some and that's
because the sugar molecule is a molecule
which where the arrangement of atoms
there are two different forms of the
arrangement of atoms one that one would
call right-handed one that woman call
left-handed it's got kind of like one is
a right handed screw third where there's
a thing sticking out in those things
sort of curling around that way and
there's also a left-handed version and
if you make sort of sugar by by just
chemical reactions and things you get
about equal numbers of left and
right-handed molecules but in life in
living systems where only right-handed
sugars know left-handed sugars in fact
it's big question if you get to my once
did this it's like does left-handed
sugar taste sweet or bitter on your
tongue um and the its some so I believe
some people it tastes sweet and some
people it tastes bitter um but but
right-handed sugar is what all all life
on Earth has in it so as a question why
is it right-handed sugar why did why did
life pick right-handed sugar not
left-handed sugar and why does it why
does it have a preference for right or
left-handed sugar so nobody really knows
but here's a bizarre fact the it used to
be thought that sort of right and
left-handed things would sort of occur
equally in physics but then what was
discovered originally in the 1950s was
that neutrinos have this strange
property that they're always left-handed
anti neutrinos are always right-handed
what does it mean that a neutrino is
left-handed so neutrinos have a spin
they're effectively spinning around and
they travel in a certain direction and
the it was thought for a long time you
trainers were massless they probably not
exactly massless but if you have a
massless particle then when it's
traveling in a certain direction it can
never change its spin its spin is always
aligned in a certain direction relative
to its direction of motion so neutrinos
are always left-handed so their spin is
always arranged in such a way that if
that's the direction of most
then the the spin of the neutrino is
always arranged in in the left-handed
way relative to its direction of motion
that was discovered in the 1950s that
neutrinos and as a result of that
nuclear beta decay so-called violated
parity which meant that they made a
difference between right and left-handed
things only left-handed neutrinos get
produced so okay so how does that relate
to life on earth nobody knows for sure
there's a very recent theory that
perhaps cosmic rays particles that come
from the Sun high-energy protons things
like that that they produce things like
carbon-14 which is an isotope of carbon
which is unstable with a lifetime of a
thousand years or so thousand years is
that right I think so about a thousand
years and it undergoes nuclear beta
decay and when it only goes nuclear beta
decay it has parity violation it has the
the the the things that come out from
carbon-14 decay are nuclei that are
basically spinning in a definite
direction as a result of neutrinos
spinning in their left-handed direction
so there's kind of a theory that maybe
as a result of cosmic rays in the early
Earth in the atmosphere of the early
Earth produced these basically atoms and
photons and things that were polarized
that were spinning in a particular
direction and that led to a slight
preponderance of right-handed sugars /
left-handed sugars in the the kind of
the in the in the sort of atmosphere of
the early Earth and in the oceans of the
early Earth and then at some point there
was a slight you know greater amount of
right-handed sugar and then the first
organisms started existing and they kind
of um
they replicated themselves and they kind
of went through the sort of train wrap
chain reaction of replication and
because the right hand of sugar was
slightly more likely as a result of the
sort of chain reaction the right-handed
the right hand of critters won out over
the left hand of critters that's a
theory nobody knows well that's actually
right but that's a possible theory for
right right handedness has dominated
right handed molecules dominate over
left hand molecules I mean it you know
right handedness and for humans it's a
whole different story I mean I happen to
be left-handed it's a I'm just waiting
for the the moment when the 10% of
humans who are left-handed really really
start to complain about all those things
in the world that are that are
prejudiced against left-handed people
and the my least favorite example is
computer is the command keys in computer
programs where command C command V those
are left-handed keys on an English
keyboard and that means that if you put
your mouse on the left hand side if you
have a physical mouse on the left hand
side or even if you have a to use your
left hand for a mouse
you can't simultaneously type command C
command V and move your mouse around and
it's big hard luck story for left-handed
people I it's kind of a you know Bill
Gates found Mike result happens to be
left-handed and for a long time he made
sure that Windows operating systems sort
of were were really a sort of equal
opportunity for left and right-handed
folk but at some point come on see come
on we won out just like those organisms
just like those sugars on the early
Earth won out the right-handed thing won
out over the left-handed thing but but
you know humans are actually the only
species to my knowledge who have a where
where the fraction of right and
left-handed critters is different in
humans is about 10% left-handed but our
form of left handedness I mean we have
we have just a huge amount of you know
of non symmetry in in our bodies you
know the heart is on a definite side and
so on a brain is arranged in different
ways and so on it that's why you know
one of my kids actually is left-handed
and sort of they're they're often
there are these studies that recruit
students for psychological experiments
and things and these studies often say
no left-handers know left-handed people
allowed in the study and the reason is
because the arrangement of brain areas
and left-handed people tends to be is
somewhat uncertain and tends to be
different for for different people and
so a lot of these studies particularly
ones that use fMRI to actually image
things in the brain they don't want
left-handed people because left hand
people's brains are sort of scrambled in
some way anyway um
somebody's asking do you prefer
Steven or Steve or something else yeah
that's a that's a slightly funny story
um the the name Steven my parents long
time ago sort of would always claimed
that they were innovative in in giving
me the name Steven turns out if you look
at the frequency of which first names
were used the the name Steven was
becoming super super common back when I
was when I was born so so not a lot of
points there but the funny thing is
there's a big lump if you look at the
number of Stevens particularly in the
u.s. there were Stevens were very common
about 60 years ago as a first name and
so but in the u.s. people the name
Steven was usually shortened to Steve
and so it's it's kind of an absolutely
deterministic thing that if I'm talking
to somebody who's like 65 years old or
older and they're American
they will always call me Steve and you
know you really can't even tell them you
say no actually my name is Steven
they'll just call me Steve I'd say it's
a it's a dead giveaway so to speak of of
them of kind of it it's a very age
dependent thing younger people it's not
the case but but so so I don't call
myself that but but it's sort of amusing
that anybody over the age of about 65 an
American will call me Steve um okay
oh gosh I've been going I've been going
much longer than I expected here so I
think I should wrap up here but these
were some really terrific questions and
I will hope to continue next week and I
can start with some of these questions
or please come again and we ask these
questions and I'll take it from there
so thanks a lot hope hope you found this
fun it's been fun for me see